357 me they are they are my ass Rafa
company they are so bad
what who actually makes them that was
great no but like who whose semen is it
know who makes the clothes do you know
like did it oh you know what's worse
they are found make their worn a cost
you pound that will exploit it in China
then built of North strata bombs are
like 15 colossal and there these are
some fit quality that is they want them
in the wrong size and man they will
animate it was 16 credit the most them
are getting in here already also meet
pok pok on video create still for that
on Puckle
so Jordan Paul and Tim from we donate
nutrition Reba krauser Tyneside warrior
programming build up north and about 45
other businesses as well back today hi
hey Chris I know you how was regionals
good Tim you got is good good time out
there
have fun all the way three really
different experience for is already but
in a coaching aspect why different
Jordan wasn't there competing
as we see the other side of it how did
you find it first time it was just we
had it was like it was like super
relaxed whereas normally it's obviously
quite intense isn't it like yeah I bet
for a certain time you opened a certain
time you're stressing about stuff like
there was not enough so it was cool just
chill now just chill the night it was it
was used to be honest no Jenny's new top
row and but to be honest it was like
it's very poor favor horn-like after the
team of being on it was like great but
then that first day just dragged on so
long as that was the first day the one
with the most it had the longest events
and so like the after the team had been
on the team were finished by like 10 10
or 11 and then that was homeless was up
triple three yeah we that all six what
should be over on the treadmill farthing
I saw that was did anyone throw because
I saw those videos of people in our
region that it's been phenomenal it's
been a lot of time like throw up down
himself and I think what they let's get
the finish line to do on the finish line
yeah clapping earth first time I've been
there for cooped up for myself already
yeah was screaming at me keep going I
was running in a therapy wooden shoes
yeah cranking squats but yeah who's
intense a lot more intense even know
like what even though like we weren't
leaving the team and I'm someone else
doing that felt like you're being
present and like proper wash the invest
in the team and then two different
individual athletes air with us directly
and then one with Tim just like your
heart was in your mouth for the entire
weekend and they even if you have one
event go well for one person it chance I
wouldn't go well for the other one so
you just end up just like I don't know
it was a close to pay for three days
yeah desperately
so yeah just wanting everyone to succeed
and obviously like you know no one got
to the game soul obviously it was like
it levels of success vary depending
whether it was like overcoming something
that was due your break in
do all you know having things in the bag
that when you go on the floor just
doesn't pay off for me and it's just
like hi mouth the whole time
I mean I'm having something that I think
about like a week later I'm actually
pretty chill about it now a lot of thing
I like I think I was very like you know
we had people in the region of the week
after that we had like an athlete in in
a region in a line in America and then
the week after we had it there was a
team in team in the region region plus
like a whole bunch of friends oh my god
even though they're all growing you know
we have program for our people who like
or we know we talked on a personal level
the bike like Willie like a sportin him
a few irons he's a good guy like I
wanted him to do well Willie we need
more Willie at the games and Kirsten
it's you know meg was there and other
people that we've kind of work with in
the past are really close friends to us
yeah
younger so do you feel so when someone
like megalith Grove or Alex young it who
have maybe built a foundation either
within the gym more within diet side or
within the training side once they've
moved on
do you still feel like a level of
ownership of their performance to a
degree not with I wouldn't say no I
would say ownership because like not
okay I would say ownership but I'd say
it's nice to see that I always come back
the same thing that like a tiny little
gem from the Northeast it's kicking out
all these good athletes and you know
like we've got people who you know I
might turn this from my lives around the
corner for me
yeah like who's my best friend I don't
know he's on the opposite and I was a
mess inside the world completely
ridiculous so ready yeah it's a great
theme part of it though like the journey
you've get in those guys from a certain
level and now the right appear in
different regions right around the world
and seen that progress yeah yes it's
been a lotta periodized right it's
contributing oh yeah no we're not
involved right now yeah it's nice it
master to have been involved at some
project really you want me to do bad
weather with you a little bit like bingo
that's being honest but at the same time
like yet of all our friends and we still
talk to them alright
on a social level yeah so like that
there was a girl I Easter program for in
the Meridian region she came like false
in France right slightly purified I
listened she left like last year this is
program that nutrition Joey but are
slightly bitter about it if you did well
it's great that I was gonna say when we
were smaller though we were smaller
Annette ever like and everyone was like
really caught you were close to everyone
I think it was a little bit harder when
people left I mean I'm smaller on like
you know that yeah especially like the
gym was much more family-oriented and
when people left it was like but Monty
member you finally moving away it was
like haha I want was there you know so
thank you all some pictures for
ourselves and the team in a gym so you
like she helped you guys contribute but
in but in reality you know of like as
that happens more and more and
CrossFit's more popular people don't get
jobs well it's a scaling up isn't it oh
yeah you know you have one place not 100
leave seems like a lot you have just
seven out of seven hundred it's the same
thing it's just the thing is well I
suppose that the business now you know
we don't make nutrition amore a
programming a service in an awful awful
lot of athlete but varying levels you
know they've got a number of different
packages and it's like well where are
you obviously you want to be able to
demonstrate your your programming with
athletes are the absolute pinnacle of
the sport yeah but there's no reason in
and of itself why some are making it to
the games is any more impressive than
someone go from completely sedentary to
being a good local level crime image
that's more impressive yeah Mayon it's
just nice less lesser claim to us how
would you see it's always good on the
fly I think those guys who are who are
going for the games and I have those
aspirations they're a lot more like you
need he's not the right term but they're
a lot more needy
you know they require a lot more
attention and need a lot more attention
they need stuff to be and explain to
them because they want to understand how
does that like need to have
understanding whereas people at that
lower level
that's getting big if they get better
than happy they don't want in a while
again another have there's probably
celebs low hanging fruit okay Chris been
doing our vehicle is where Lakes
potential at that early stage is watch
just how quick they can grow compared to
the flat oh then it just marginal gain
that because finite you know like on the
first start doing especially something
that's even semi M semi boot slice
followed it's it's so much more
productive for them so that they saw of
curves and getting better as like so
aggressive I mean I yeah I imagine the
allowing some of your athletes to step
out one at the competition floor after
you've been with them for ages and
prepped them and build them up must be
similar to the feeling that I've got
about atom free corns done he's got this
roughly hewn rock that I found and
you've polished it and buffed it for
years and years and oh you've calmed it
down and then you've say oh it's wedding
veil that he's now about two hundred
thousand followers on Instagram
um well again you know like he's a lot
more famous than you know he is in some
of our athletes some of your athletes
can deadlift more than you though do you
feel mad about them that's true that's
three times you know sorry deadlifts
which was Saturday in Clovis which is in
January we just got to fill the dips in
and we're done from here in fact well
when dips as well that's fine anything
matter EPS no yeah you know and we saw
Adam do we see undo some thrusters
the TV yeah I was Norman also I wasn't
happy about the amount of noise that was
coming out there I mean what with the
weights heavy wasn't our X there's a
scale scale definitely scale
it's like bro it's 50 kilo steady on did
he do burpees he saw dumbbell thrusters
but he's looking around the Meister he
was doing them so soon he's doing quite
a lot
mmm 15 pretty there I don't need you in
the open or someone's girlfriend you did
look you know I see somebody came up and
said that's me you do know only bunch of
sweaty so whatever is byproduct of
behind metabolism yeah says you can't
look like that unless you're it's
impossible yeah that's what they said
it's just I don't know much about the
oil situation under Authority ferrites
you liked it bucks and maybe I'll listen
since a likes open in your skin or and
then there's a reason yeah why are
awfully sweaty when he off the warm-up
run well we do strength portions of the
workout and I sweat like it's cardio so
yeah you just watch I've ever beat on
now actually when it's all about it your
honor but I thought you were stopping by
the kilowatts
Tom how did that happen his tongue mmm
Ben's I think he went from he's barely
time to begin with like a five
change race now both borderlines go for
it
borderline he's very dark it's very dark
well I think naturally he's into some
old days yes that's quite dark but I my
darkest I've ever been in my life was
after I came off and that was after like
three and a half weeks of came off what
the solids because yeah you've it's just
high velocities sun rays you know all
the time and all you're wearing shorts
to about a dining act it is yeah on the
minute every minute yeah sure so we've
got two topics that we can talk about
huh one of them is going to be mindset
one of them is going to be nutrition
which ones you want to go for today go
mindset that's called mindset because I
think it'll be good for you to do on
with Tim you'll nutrition could already
separate analysis leave cool
so my question my main question about
mindset within sport is you guys try and
prepare your athletes as best as
possible with periodization for strength
energy levels for the mood
yeah managing everything that you can to
get them to have the highest ability at
the highest access to all of their
potential output or performance within
let's say across their competition but
the same would be true if you were a
gymnast if you were if the same would be
true if you were a power lifter or
presumably a martial artist yeah
whatever whatever it is um but the
biggest mediator of someone's output of
their potential it's whether or not in
their mind they tell themselves to do it
like if someone is in the middle of a
really long horrible workout while their
lungs are burning and the legs are
aching and that mind is telling them to
stop them telling themselves not to stop
makes all the difference in the world
yeah hundred percent how do you train
that how do you how do you how to so I'd
say the best don't have that question in
the head yeah I think if you look at
anybody sorry if there's any doubt in
the head of I need to stop you're
probably not gonna be up there anyway
like if you look like anybody who's
successful in any athletic field any
other I feel so like Ronaldo as a
footballer you know famous American
footballers or anything like that like
none of them have a doubt about their
ability a lot that's supposed to be
there the old believe that are supposed
to be there no carburetor for example
like six years ago he was living on
benefits now he made a hundred his
fourth from Forbes this last area like
you know he's just he's got that ability
and he's got that that mindset that
allows him to do that and nobody's told
him that he's just he's had it we all
know the name we all know that when you
get deeper it will work out especially
as specifically with CrossFit I think is
one of the reasons I said on the first
podcast that he did one of the reasons I
think CrossFit is a an engaging
spectator sport the same the same reason
that the Tour de France is the N observe
this suffering yeah and you can see
people as they go in and out of
themselves battling with their own will
yeah if you can't Herrick t-cell them as
well we all know we all know that as you
say you know a lot of these guys have
got this unwavering self belief but put
yourself half-an-hour deep into a really
really horrible workout yeah it kind
that mindset gets tested well it's a
different environment as life it does
it's just for me and I think it's one
things that you can develop it for sure
but I think you develop me through
through training so you develop the tool
like I saw silver my gold might be
suffering like when you turn up it's
like that that angel thing like train
hard play easy like train harder than
the competition's ever going to be so
when you get there it doesn't feel that
bad like if you've got to do seven
events over three days train 20 you know
what I mean like and then they got
coaches jobs yeah exactly so can we step
in you should have your athletes should
be prepared for hell like so so mine
it's the mindset of I
the physical training then to a degree
personally I think it is I think there's
more going into it so you've got that
side then you've got what you've grown
up with so you're born with this innate
sense of hard work and that's developed
on with childhood with your parents have
their distilled that int yeah Artie
they're gonna be those guys telling you
to Charles around the house or maybe
like if he dad wasn't then you have to
deal with things and step up a level
mmm I think and look after those around
you I mean you like just builds upon it
like everybody's everybody who's at the
top has suffered setbacks along the way
in terms of the childhood yeah oh I've
been through things like rich Froning
had to do loads when he was a kid
loads and loads of chores around the
house and it's just hard work was
distilled in it yeah rich Froning senior
looks like a proper tough tough yeah he
does like injuries there's a lake
something needs cutting Soviet needs
chopping and when you apply all that
into an athlete then throw them in the
gym then the see success with it and
it's not growing growing your own
foundations you have the foundations to
build then you apply the training to it
yeah
but obviously 20 workout is there's
nothing that would stop you from
inheriting an athlete who hasn't had
ideal foundation mm-hmm and when they
get deep in it will work out that they
get a lot of negative self-talk that
comes through so I think we manage it in
different ways so I think like I think
with each tear tired because these two
like two robust bastards who will push
themselves hard and workouts so typical
relate to his own personal thing Tim
will bar himself 205 fusions of you have
0% the desk you subdued a couple discs
yeah in a badly yeah badly you need new
your knees the atomic telephone yes
Tim's tips problems in decals vinyl was
developed for Timbers mm-hmm but I can
go for spinal now and that's completely
fine no you can say I'm sore buffed with
my spine it's fun
well it's one disc isn't it no but with
Tim yes paalam isn't stopping him he's
probably as a value born stop yeah and
Jotham the same he's pretty well at
least preying on for that one himself
pointed in yeah so I think we've got
multiple levels I think like on a gym
level and like on a regular culture it's
just the culture that the court she said
still because in the gym the merge area
time where I was there homie IRA was
there yeah so they're always gonna get
more of it so self talk probably gets
overridden by our chat and present our
motivation our presents exactly so
there's that fear factor that we're
always there we're watching its eyes on
get more now that down as well again
you'll always see people in first of all
I just can't do it Mike well you can
because you've done third you're the rep
so you've only got twenty laugh yeah
I've already done more than what you've
got left to do you may as well finish so
it's so funny and anyone who's listening
or know exactly the same pain that I
feel when one of the coaches walks by
and you hanging out with your ass and
you've got twenty thrusters left in a
workout of 50 kilos and it's really
really heavy and someone will say how
many of you got how many of you don't
know how many of you got left and you
say the number and you know that all
they're gonna say is well pick the
[ __ ] bar oh yeah I mean like yeah
yeah may I know
well no am i dating oh yeah well you
don't think you've her fancies picking
the bar if I have already [ __ ] picked
it up but was being then you picked the
bar I pick it up more anyway we might
piss you off enough yet I look at a
picture borrow I tell you who I always
feel picked on me call them out Ben
Kennedy generation or a [ __ ] I don't
think that's the case I think so Ben's
been just only me Ben doesn't have the
baby oil steel they'll be terrible when
he's in a wetsuit
I know he needs to swim you get wet suit
rush but then again wouldn't even really
streamlined without the wetsuit
no no need for a white yeah so in the
gym you're basically forced into it will
believe so okay so a couple so now but
also your turned up for that though yeah
yeah you're not expecting so with that
you'd there'd be more than Betty push
therefore through experience you're
gonna realize that you can because we've
told you you can and therefore
eventually you'll believe in yourself
and other doesn't Asian therefore that
comes on to you can kind of like the
same way as a someone who's got
substance dependency Wiens themselves
off it the end himself buttress that is
your motivation and you being over them
in you have a lot of a spend more time
yeah cuz I've always thought like you
know you are right
this if I'm ever doing programming
that's written for myself and I'm doing
it with a partner you're always going to
be almost always work hard Expo yeah
going to put yourself in that same Hall
when it's just you now part of
environment as well like officers were
really applied to most top-level
athletes because the majority isn't
trained on their own bottom here till
like general gym population like it is
that shared suffering like everybody's
going through the same thing I'm used in
the same thing so you think well you
know he's 65 over that he's doing it so
striking out I'm sure I can do it you
know so I think that in itself is quite
motivating and quite am quite powerful
yes I guess people - I mean that's it's
on that rating level on that training
level then most of that that kind of
like self-talk is taken away more of it
by the coach is motivated by the people
around you motivated by the environment
therefore in that level that's fine the
issues become is when all of a sudden
you have to become autonomous hmm and
then you're not there in their ear yeah
and that's when the demons creep in
that's when the fear that's when you
just looked at some other prick doing
like a bigger snap than you want to
Instagram and they're about to be at the
same competition of you which does not
many snatch it in but that doesn't
matter because they got 3,000 like
anxiety comes to it all of that's
important men once told me about a
workout she'd done I think he was
something to do with snatches and you
were in there and she was like really
really unhappy during this workout yeah
being constantly going and you had been
a cheap she said she wanted to give up
you said you're not [ __ ] giving up
apparently kept on doing snatches closer
and closer to a wall yeah and then once
she completed it with that pretty much
with tears streaming down her face he
threw the keys at her and said door lock
oh I don't think I threw the key there I
think she'd modified that slightly do
you know this story that I'm talking
about she was facing the wall crying
quite heavily yeah right do you think
that something like that oh I thought so
for certain athletes do you think that
kind of breaking down those barriers and
pushing him through it because I know
that she found that a very it out the
other side at the time probably not very
happy afterwards I know that she found
that a very rewarding experience yeah
but I found it very valuable
I didn't softballs her into that though
that wasn't me like she's at him she's
like powerfully who understands exactly
we were she was bad she was preparing
for regionals we were doing it on our
own she got first individual climb we
looked at the programming and wrote for
something that we felt was definitely
gonna challenge your tester but we but
we knew that we knew that the way it's
in the Lord were going to be more
testing than what she's done in the gym
crying for time so we gave her a workout
to do and she was just having an
argument with a south facing a wall
saying warriors on you give me this the
prove to me that I can't do it
and then she started screaming at us up
that she was gonna prove me wrong and
then she started adding on else that
well I was there well yeah yeah yes do
you dance so she we should move
attacking with herself yeah and then she
broke into tears yeah wall but she got
to the end of it and realized that she
could do the thing that she thought she
could do yeah for her I think that was
like a pretty good moment I come I might
break money management for her because
she realized she was capable and that
wasn't trying to trim it open or open or
lot more than she thought yeah I think I
was I think that was a really good
moment part you have do you have breath
like obviously that's quite a obvious
example of something that was really
really apparent but do you have other
moments or breakthrough moments with
athletes that you work with where you
can kind of see that they see the other
side of the capabilities a little bit or
does it always is it just a parrot-like
as a matram sorry where they just go
from being good to better - even better
- I think one of the clients she had a
really bad year at Regionals and vision
if I started working with her and she
sort of DQ'd on one of the workouts and
wasn't able to proceed so they're on the
competition or not start heavily with
her and I think what after a few
conversations prepare and some strong
training sessions and some belief in at
the time there was a phrase that are now
[ __ ] here which is stay in your lane
and that at the time resonated with her
and for her it was actually this switch
of like I can manage my own [ __ ] if it
judge knows wrecks me I can stop and
manage that situation in a much better
way yeah if I just leave and just
looking at the judge and said tell me
what I'm doing wrong yeah because you
look that many no reps on
ball is that she just kept frying
herself out and getting more emotional
about the situation at a time and then
for her it was quite a simple mindset
shift it was hang on I can stop for five
seconds and get no more no raps
yeah if I just think edge you're my
judge and say you know what but you
would post you or me it did yeah that
this that multiple times of different
things but yeah it's like one of those
things like the way I always think about
it is you work so hard to get there
so hard to get there like why let an
alright get in the way of it you gotta
know where just crack on just do another
don't make thoughts though yeah like you
know like the judge was no rep nice for
something that was a rep like to be fair
should give me the reps on the like
weather shouldn't have been reps so I
can't really complain if you yeah but
you don't take two people it's give and
take what you don't like I could off
like other athletes did that weekend
stood there and shout than a face but
then like what what good does that do
cushion she's not giving us the reps so
all I didn't was just turned finish the
workout and then I was it like didn't go
back complain didn't put a complaint in
this there's no point they're not gonna
give you any reps back so what kind of
yeah just does not want well my like I
came I think it came seventh nerve and I
could probably came third yeah
good man first 26 could ship fit and
chemists yeah it's not like I was gone
the game so yeah if you go emotional
side like if you were yes so I so I
eventually look like do you look like a
[ __ ] as well everyone in the stands
were like no crow about it and he wasn't
he has he only one car was Picasso versa
you've got no right yeah yeah he was
like it's one of those one of those
thing they like everyone so he realized
like it is one of those things we want
to our that's yeah that's part of the
reason why you're a good role model for
the gym or everything pretty good
athletes and for me yeah so what why are
your thoughts on is regionals is
completely finished alright don't know
yet so what what is that's what your
thoughts on the workouts that got issued
this year I think it's I think it's
really tough though look it's like
there's just no consistency with the
program it so it's like just I
understand that the sport is like
unknown and unknowable but I think there
should be a bit of consistency with like
the tests like the open you kind of know
what you're gonna get regionals it
should kind of be the same like there it
should kind of be a formula you have to
follow like I don't know everything can
go from being with the dumbbell last
year so this year there's no dumbbells
in there yeah but I was alone yeah to
demelza's and I'm not
Chicago now he was checked on wells and
then you got boxed it's like just had a
bit consistency about yeah that's good I
think he's trying to think of how we can
trip people up yeah more so then show
off people's fitness people did well
this year obviously the best are always
gonna do well and they're gonna qualify
but those on the outside some did really
well if that's I buy like if they can
benchpress those account benchpress
probably didn't do that well I like that
like I don't mean like it calling
everybody out was that can you explain
the workout for people who don't know
what it was
so one thing before I do that one thing
I was going to mention about the mindset
as well is that the biggest thing that I
think people saw fourth is like the fear
of failure once you get over the fact
that you might fail then you guys yeah
like if you got regionals and you fail
you still fought with fails to reach it
you know cares and you know I mean
there's only 39 people who can hold that
over so we and we did a we did a podcast
on confidence with joining Youssef
recently and one of the key things that
we took away from that in order to
maximize confidence was to relinquish
your desire to feel like you have any
level of any allowance to not be stupid
like if you wake up on a morning and you
presume that you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes all the time because that is a
byproduct of being human we can hear
they're not robots and we do make
mistakes like letting go of your desire
to have like too much dignity I suppose
to a degree yeah yeah it actually
creates a rod for your back or I should
be doing this I should be doing that you
like just do what you can
yeah trap as well as you can and then
the outcome is the outcome so we have a
great thing where mainly Wednesdays
we've done this for quite a while both
within the gym on wari program we often
program unrealistic imams oh you might
you might realize this in mind yeah
that's not so they so you did recently
the one with the it was it to triplets
the water assault bike the double unders
with the handstand push-ups it was
impossible it was I will seem does
anyone really
yeah why something possible vices things
spread it's going to be ready - it still
it's gonna know you yeah what's the
reason for them just the test mental
toughness like what can you do where do
you need to scale someone might be
amazing they might you've gone to
regionals but that might not be able to
complete just so we're putting a bit by
this workout yeah it's like how are you
gonna overcome that or can you do next
time yeah it's like that door thing
about like fail and like people get
super worried about it like when
whatever training business whatever I
just have a pop I mean I mean like the
people who are gonna have a go at you
for fail the same people that didn't
give it a go which people are going to
get better
the people who drop it back a couple of
wraps but completely other people who
just don't end up doing the workout or
you know I mean are like yeah the people
it's a 40 minute workout of moving and
suffering like [ __ ] and you're like
and you'll be frying on like you will
have done 40 minutes of hard hard
exercise and improved one way or another
and and if the whole fear is I'm not
going to be able to get through this
work then you know that you're not
learning the right lessons yeah yeah I
think and the internal dialogue when
you're going through that I mean I don't
know what it's like for you guys who've
got a lot more experience but I'd say
that I'm now probably a moderately
representative local level crossfitter
yeah in that I'm going to put that in
the Instagram bio moderately represent a
change to be honest you're one of the
only in local cross beds I know can also
do pack up yeah but it's one of them and
we're like people gets don't worry about
fairly serious there yeah I think
expectations you've got a manager that
[ __ ] will [ __ ] you all but yeah if you
go there thinking bit just where you
should be or what if you'd be you're not
focusing on what's in front of you yeah
how do you how do you do that let's say
it's a good example for regionals you
get to test the workouts in advance
you know what your time should be well I
think the environment is so different
online the only test is when you're on
the floor and what you're getting mm-hmm
and the only test is how you overcome
with that like you the amount of times
you get people who did [ __ ] in training
but then bossed it that regionals are
you or vice versa yeah but if you let
turnout if you if you if you think that
the outcome that's you all over yes
if you get the outcome of one was how it
affect how the rest of the weekend goes
the chances are like you know yeah I
should have done well in this workout
great [ __ ] story right in your little
journal there in [ __ ] I don't know
pray about it do whatever you need to do
but if you know you can't let that
single moment get to you so I think that
expectation thing is them
I think expectation will really push
people massively it's also really funny
when people do all the regional workouts
of like six seven days we do make a post
and say ok mate ok many did you say yeah
yeah I hate to scale the bend how did
you find how did you find Madrid but did
you have to run through the separate
mark now so those things as well like
like moving the chess piece engineer
barbells not so that you don't have a
few wrong with you of hefty running
between yeah Linda sorry anyway ok told
me just said we're done so what we put
this in yeah that's cutting it in color
doing and so regionals work ups this
year any highlights you mentioned Linda
Linda is so it was ten to one a deadlift
I can't remember the weight heavy heavy
heavy ish like 150 131 arms by 135 ish
yeah thanks was that like 80 84 kilos
gone Timmy that and then this squat
clean was at 65 65 think 65 it's all
these seniors isn't it well they use the
short of bars as well so it's like
naught word
weight as well the bars not 45 pounds
it's 40 so it's been off yeah
and yes it was ten ten ten nine nine
nine eighty eight all the way down to
one one one and it just crushed people
simply men attack elders rush people
like some of the poor girls bloody L do
I having a bad time without berries ice
I was gonna say from the from the [ __ ]
like just crushing the first set
deadlift it's like an absolute hero and
then just not moves you know that you're
not like this that's too much booty
bluster it's too much booty bluster my
mother
it's Hank blaster it's not enough pack
thick packed more packed a I apologize
let's get miss Jets day that's
internationally don't you do anything
miss Monday bench benches are just for
hip thrusts and refile of a purchase
that's all I follow yeah these were for
so yeah I put my stuff on the bench well
yeah use - imagination yeah not vanity
station that there's no cosmetic
something oh no how do you prop up your
phone I used to talk video made video so
I can you if I need a tripod ask Alex
Murphy cosplay there I use it to reach
the brake yeah it's gonna cricket yeah
and you close a lot they use a quail the
very versatile yeah free [ __ ] I think I
get that line on impressed way that was
my next that was definitely unexpected
the most unexpected swirl
hundred-percent yeah I would say so like
everything supposedly as well yeah I
think so triple three and three camera
300mm des three-mile run on but he did
on the skill Mel on the end run I'm
sorry
it was just like sandwich it's about
time that happened though isn't it that
there was a super long time it was I got
it in the other I didn't go though
justice no you didn't go as well when
you push uni they put a long run in then
yeah but one camera off their hunts down
push-ups one just Cameron let's make the
foreground its try did you try and do
that at work out no I haven't noticed I
haven't does I don't wanna be that guy
oh no did you put you in there oh right
so how was it I've done it but not on a
non oh yeah I think it's different
yeah I've run it I've done it running
and it's actually fine the words are
oils three words really on that and yet
cause after the double unders that's it
like actual workouts cardio to some hard
just cardio it's just harder yeah I mean
there was a lot of people if anyone
wants to look at some good videos if you
check out the CrossFit Games Instagram
and scroll back a little bit there is a
wealth of people throw your down
themselves well so for those of you
don't know what a skill mill or a true
former owner is it's like a self-powered
treadmill that moves as you strike your
foot your foot move to the actual
platform that you're on rather than it
moving and you having to keep up with it
yeah so you determine your own speed
yeah but what must have happened because
people are throwing up down themselves
as they're on this opening width or they
might have been flicking around for like
poor judges you know that when you go
through mud on your bike when you're
again and all of the back so you need
like a vomit guard on the front of the
skill now needs to protect everyone from
getting flick äj--
you know quite a few of the treadmills
turned off so the way they have to judge
it
there was a meter marked out on with the
white lines if he saw a regionals there
was white lines on the treadmill yeah
they only count how many times the white
line thought so judge to 5000 device
thousands about four thousand eight
hundred of those it's [ __ ] across
being a judge isn't it yeah it isn't ha
it's a hardly 300mm is a ha it's a hard
weekend my Mike you been depressed see
that is already yeah that's pretty cool
news yeah there's not a thing is you
literally can't be them and then all of
a sudden I'm like [ __ ] knows it's really
[ __ ] boring there's a little know your
pics or something so I got to watch I
got to watch him Sam Briggs sorry
sequence daughter and Emma McQuaid do
18.3 yeah and while the coaches have
across the club Lysander had to judge
some bricks remaining that he was gonna
go and do 18.3 afterwards and be judged
by them yeah before he went over us like
make you more nervous to judge her doing
her I fell for her juju and it's like
Hamed was like yeah yeah it was like
here you can see him there but like to
achieve why isn't it 400 double unders
twice right so like 800 chances to get
it wrong yes it was like 100 double
unders than someone else than 100 of
them also else yeah - well yeah 204 out
yeah
your opportunities to make yet exactly
in between everything else then you
could see from the side and he's good
other thing is like even more focus that
you've ever seen someone in their life
like it definitely definitely had more
more single-mindedness went judging the
way when actually is so much relief even
drinking hims pretty tough yeah I'm bout
of the night wonders like so no no you
cannot just do you feel a bit like you
nervous about it because you know they
were dawning right you know the property
clinic Hetson one of them I've ever and
I'm a graduate John one sitting in a
workout as one that actually got
monitored I actually got viewed by
regionals wasn't it yeah and literally
I've just finished like judging him and
just finished out the video and stuff
well actually someone can be Army was
like I wouldn't give him those reps and
I would I know bro I was like and then I
then I had to literally go off the job
and then go have you can watch the video
on albro think you might need to do
together
but we watch the video back and we just
like we just like because you can slow
it down if you'd not if that had been
sent off and CrossFit heard HQ it AG
decayed that you had given him reps it
shouldn't have been reps with the Lotus
you know it doesn't really it doesn't
really it's not really no I'm not
definition always been approved it's not
make sure the video disallowed because I
think think you get the choice to do it
again right so I think the safety look
you can do it again and you can repeat
the score you donating video with and
we'll accept your score well not give
you any more but will not take anything
away okay or will give you a penalty so
if it's less than like three off I think
if it's less than five reps don't give
you a penalty okay if it's more than
five they subtract fifteen percent of
his goal so there is a spectrum Aida I
thought it was I thought it was like you
because I mean you get you get so many
British yeah yeah like Joe Joseph
yeah but like what was weird about
Martin HQ it proved it approved the
video and accepted it and then there was
backlash from it then the Cromwell's one
of the hands ton press ups this year not
it I heard about it but I didn't
demonstrate away each other she filmed
it on a potato about 300 yards distance
from a 40 angle as well yeah was from
like from the floor she got regionals
this year yeah did you call girls games
oh [ __ ] oh well that's just how much I
watch it's handstand push-ups in there
it went on the reddit so read it's like
just a melting pot for people who have
to be during the fair yeah yeah they
this video particularly when people
start scrutinizing it and CrossFit have
got a reddit account and they relied on
that and they said something to the
effect of the video isn't the video
isn't required to be proof of the
athletes score is to be an example of
their work capacity to be able to
complete it so it's like the actual
score area didn't matter
it's that she demonstrated that she
could have got the score oh let's just
like that was me coming out of nowhere
with her score yeah completing the work
out there's no feet on the wall for the
enhanced and that's where people that
said people like on a 20 minute book I
run a 60 minute 5k that's my business
it's hard isn't it goes like you only
have to put video submission in if they
ask for the video be whether you're
doing it without a judge and you know
like you're in the middle of nowhere and
you having to send your videos in to be
approved yeah therefore any other videos
that get posted really are irrelevant
well obviously they highlight if you're
a bit of a cheating [ __ ] or you're not
very good with your reps yeah like it
highlights what you're doing because
that one guy I think I mention it I
sound the podcast that one guy that
golden blog too but wasn't locking out
wasn't locking out with push press and
like flexing this judge was job job Box
Tops his judge was judging him he was
doing the rep he was just doing what
he's judge said yeah he was like yeah I
got this amazing score then I would know
where one of his members who was in the
background like you know filming it he
shot with Norway posted it online
look how good my coach is bossing this
and then literally everyone times
CrossFit it'll just they lost everyone's
like slides him off idiot buggies full
gym got disqualified Oh Jim Oh Mike that
member doesn't brother around I mean at
the very least that members got to they
need to take a weekend increase in fees
like yeah oh
you're a solid bike on the new
renaissance un nouveau remember we just
budget at the court for the boss joe
mean and heat was happy because the
judge had told him he got the rent so
needs to be a line drawn in the sun
somewhere right yeah and apparently not
anywhere near brook walls no yeah yeah
very much so
so well since you know that Stadium and
thing yeah it's got fuck-all to do with
me she's nine our region she's Norrell's
I don't even aunt read it is like yeah
they should forgive - well yeah they
should soft you ready this made for you
they just are like super great it's like
forums main person in it they should
sort it out by all meanings but like I
don't really give a [ __ ] about all these
whiny CrossFitters wind your new car you
can do it on some project themselves
complaining about it Brooke Wells potato
you know she's proven that you can I
didn't see the video I learned over
there she's probably really good at
CrossFit maybe she should be there lol
going forever I can only a link to
thread in the show notes so if you want
to check a little bit more about this on
reddit then you'll be able to so else at
Regionals was there anything else that
you thought that was either good or not
I am I thought the rest of the weekend
was good like the events were really
good really really challenging visually
quite cool right is a McGann word with
the bars yeah yeah I like that I think
venue is pretty decent then you were
talking food was terrible with people
hydrate this time Berlin so yeah food in
the in the venue was terrible
just like nobody it's supplied by the
venue I mean can you imagine let's say
let's say that we did it in the NEC Ohio
I don't know something about me or
whatever if and it was held in the UK
and you got cowboy kitchen to go and the
anchors follow key but they've cleared
the food would be legit but in my
company and a couple years ago that's
what they did so that was like it's
lying outside and you went outside there
was like a huge picnic area and the
nailed it in Copenhagen I don't know why
they're so good it was a little bit out
of the wave what like it was nice and
with people from Copenhagen mr. Mac
still part of our region
they're like Northern Europe now but
that still falls in our regional so I
don't know why never moved it from there
but um it was good it was good it was
good fun my last poem on spectator
spectator fastest thing was a bit of it
was bigger thing a little bit not too
hard they just sold out really quickly
and then people weren't quite prepared
and tinea lounge and I was like that's
all the coffees but no it was good it
was good yeah it's just long a long
weekend and very very different nothing
for all of what how much should I pull
how much sleep do you get regionals
actually no I want to ask I've got asked
if you know what actually do you get
first off in general went yeah then how
do you how much sleep you get when it's
the Thursday I have some work outfits
and I have to be really honest at like
this year maybe didn't handle it the
best this year I think like last year we
had like three athletes and then this
year I think we had 18 did it feel like
spinning and with it well God by 40 yeah
we've all got 40 I think so I tend to
lean over across
no no no that's people actually made it
to regionals and I think Tim's got a few
games athletes now and so I think him so
I think something you know that's the
people who qualify not just all of the
other between however many minds like
you know the extra 400 500 people we've
got doing it yeah so I think this year I
think yeah I don't think I've slept I
don't think I slept for five weeks
what about um when the open goes out on
that Thursday night can you tell me what
because I know that I've signed a
seminar with you before and you've said
to the athletes who are trying to
perform at high level for bed
yeah go to bed do not stay up and watch
it that's my job yeah and I've heard you
said that sentence is that how you work
how you do things when the open that's
how I did that's how I did it that's why
did it again it last round here okay so
I stayed and watched it and then I was
in first in the gym at 6:06 a.m. to set
two point eight down on your name
zombunny came in been yeah so we went
there and set that up
it's all wrong and then you've been you
on the phone to athletes all there and
then you know if the workout doesn't got
a plan or other people do you know you
for every two I think to have a great
workout then I have a whole [ __ ]
bunch of other [ __ ] sure do you mean and
it's managing that expectation for out
five weeks and I think I think I could
definitely have handled that like in
terms of the quantity bear mmm but again
like it's kind of the best five weeks
ever at the same time yeah so you can't
really yeah its prestige hence yeah it
was the best but isn't it yeah it's just
it is the best five weeks it just you
just like what's going on
oh wait like yeah where's the parallel
that I can draw with my industries when
it's Halloween yeah it's Halloween I'll
do 10 nights yeah yeah and I'll get up
on November the first and be like well
how like where's this what's that's two
weeks of my life gone like yeah barely
awake during daylight and the
yeah and you like you write like these
I'm aware that it's not the same as
pushing yourself through a marathon but
in a to a degree it kind of is and Wendy
said milestone it's [ __ ] over it'll
start I mean even if you walk at you're
finished in six like undermined
equipment I found a great balance this
year is like an athlete coach and young
nutritionist mm-hmm so arm didn't watch
it whatsoever in the lead up looked at
my phone woke up in the morning so the
workout cool didn't look at my phone
till I finished the workout so I have to
do the workout by 10:00 a.m. okay cuz I
had a certain I thought you'd say so yes
I'd all my messages building up and
building up and building up literally
saying what with ye meter this thirst is
what ye yeah what's why you know sobbing
oh if the sisters because apples it have
no apples is for thrusters right yeah
and then but I'll ask for everything
else yeah understand anything else
except the and stop pushing the top hair
sorry yeah you're right yes pads rock
yeah yeah so I just let all the emails
mount up until I'd finished the workout
about ten and I'll just stop my phone
for a couple of hours you know did all
my work all my emails got my film
clients so could enjoy the rest of the
day so I didn't have anything
social media wise and fill up finish the
workout this sounds like you firm not
really work phone I was gonna say it
sounds like you've got good luck doing
the same structure that people realize
that you can replicate that make sure
yeah yeah I'm gonna do one Tim's doing
it's gonna be much better yeah oh you
know what you need to do you need Tim to
program your program yeah ready for our
Imam of them alternating between coffee
and knockos yeah that's pretty much it
no I'm so it was really fun it was just
it was just really intense this year but
it was cool but it was it was very
different welcomes like new region yeah
and you ignited a new format less people
going and say let's talk about the fact
that the teams have now moved from six
people to four yeah just has been
released when we did our first popular
one hadn't so what's what what does that
mean for Jim's overall I know I think I
think the war such brute of mayhem got
three team name acquit to the Invictus
have got to as well
and they both both qualified for the
games yeah I think that's just like it's
a lot more it's better to watch for
definite because when there was six and
you've got like eight lanes of six
people on the field like I see a field
but you know what I mean in the field of
play dough it's like what's going on be
chaotic it looks like you've took a lot
of kids to like yeah
chucky cheese or whatever and just fill
them free coke there was a workout there
which was like two people were doing
chess about pull-ups two people running
if that have been the six if there would
have been someone else doing something
else somewhere else and it just ends up
being like this big chaos so just you
would still I think it was a bet for a
lot of weight that pass general I think
you only know what the better quality of
competition is well because that that
most gyms have two good people because
you know the males to good females that
third one this is going to come across
bad and I don't mean it to but the kind
of like the weakest link basically they
all kind of very nature they are you
know that the weakest link so by having
the two and the two you you have a much
stronger team so then the events were a
lot more watch yeah and I mean you saw
it this year was like the amount of like
um the amount of minimum work
requirements that were hit that wind hit
sorry there wasn't many that it's about
yeah but even then there was only two in
our region three now remember it's ten
percent in our regional which is nothing
in comparison to other years where okay
there was people getting stopped on the
first day so tune it to for one of a
better term there's more people getting
to regionals that are all the regionals
standard yeah yeah I would say so and I
think it's even even with the teams if
the teams do well but within that that
work requirement is is not met by
particular element I saw one was which
also can affect a couple or a patient I
say yeah yeah that's an identifier of
the fact that yet there's some people
that kind of being pulled that maybe
hanging up the coattails of athlete to
it yeah I've ever standard that they're
not quite out yet Declan oh yeah which
you know was really like it's night so I
went to regionals it's like well yeah
it's still I've got the team Cup yeah
like oh look it's a tough one because
it's like you know but the sport is it's
a competitive sport with sponsorships
and money involved and all these things
like it's no longer 2010 like you're not
rocking up with a pair of board shorts
and cracking on it's a legit sport now
so you know it's not be free everything
level there's not gonna be trapped like
a legit sport then you don't have places
for I like that I think that there's we
always talked we didn't last podcast
talking off a lot about the inclusivity
a local level of CrossFit that yeah
allows people of from sedentary to
actually quite fit rugby player
endurance athlete whatever it is to go
in and find training methodology which
is challenging and rewarding yeah yeah
but regionals is definitely not the
place for inclusivity anymore no we
don't you know as we see even in some
respects is that the open as well sorry
I interrupted there but they open as
well you know like the scaling options
now are not really scale options like
the scale options were poke skipping
pops I can come up to the gym is a big
deal
yeah they're gonna feel about the first
Kip post we're still high five and
running around and it's still a huge
moment where were you know they were
either guys yourself like that now it's
like oh you know could post no button
paints and register for the I'm gonna
get cut up a savage yeah so it's like
it's bringing the standards of ever
bringing their standards of every cent
off but the bringing the standards of
coaching up then because you're like
right next year we must get like that
you challenging gyms to get to that
point but that's that's it that's an
interesting point so Dave Castro said in
a video I think it's like 2013 2014 he
says it wouldn't surprise me if in X
number of years time we'll see male
athletes who can run a five minute mile
that can deadlift 500 pounds and can
snatch like 120 kilos or something like
that that you've got someone who is
going to be as good in every speciality
is the best within their division now
yeah well across every different domain
yeah obviously what that means is and
you know there's a
work out every year in CrossFit right
yeah and they always come at it their
last one last one they always compare
what happened last time with what
happened this time and the statistics
are this volume of like the Josh bridge
is one the one eighteen point five when
it was eleven point six or some da last
time and the score that he got that was
the quickest in the world remembering
that he did it again this year is the
same guy but just with another seven
years on him or whether that score was
beaten the best score on the planet was
beaten by like three hundred people
yeah or something like that's some crazy
thing but also it's again a numbers as
well because you know it was back in
2011 week much wider man CrossFit it was
it was two thousand people registered
three thousand people registered in
Europe for the open this year was 35
that's times by ten so you know that the
table that's what you want massive the
most being massive so I mean like yeah I
mean there's a lot of people in our gym
but a few put a larger who did that work
out it doesn't love me included I think
I got like six more reps I've got it
right yeah ready yeah I think that's
good but you were you had AIDS I thought
was gonna die because we my thought was
been meningitis I meant I fight yeah and
they're false fire 114 bricks on the
back of oh yeah yeah 14 bricks I mean
like my open experience wasn't very good
this year
it wasn't good at all performed well and
contributed to the team which was the
most important thing yeah but um I mean
there's a couple of workouts that you
were talking about 18.3 should should
have been your jam right well 8.3 I mean
I came back for is in our region but
that was no way the first workout or
done after you know if we have eaten a
solid meal for like you know I had tuned
off weeks off and I couldn't repeat it
again because I was I was literally
broken I got coughing the lung up after
Tim judges I was I was dying so I think
I did five sessions in five weeks and
they were just the open workout the
amount of people about elder in the open
was right yeah once you're older you
need some money you don't want to manage
immunity did never call it enough went
across what
probably right wasn't called enough that
was the trouble with anybody I remember
it was when it was stock waiter would
you know whether it was there but when
we will they prove everyone wasn't able
to do one which was it was an eighteenth
point father snow when there was snow
drift was any point to that was the
clean one yeah that was the thing I
learned because I was off and they
[ __ ] crush it yeah that's true yeah
but I mean that they're all so I mean
they're all unlike people with my
football giving a sorry Sigma started
tobogganing to the gym and 40s there's
none crushed down by a bike there wasn't
a good time
well mergency crashed my car I didn't I
couldn't drive it put his Chi my hips 14
totally walk straight past him ruin
classics you wouldn't help dodgy I'm
Scott Jim Scott came and grabbed me and
then I went back and told them the world
of it run no he didn't he tried to push
news like that it's best if you leave me
hey thanks okay I was right
yeah yeah gonna throw it out okay
players were specialists yeah yeah Gary
so deal with me you did what Ben
Kennedy's can't approach isn't it he
just takes like five twenty kilo plates
for the Jews have a better approach
don't buy BMW
that's a better approach in hi boy it's
Tim's degree make Tim's green mm-hmm
make hundred kilos in the boutique ah
yeah yeah Jenny's dog out and like a
touching like snow behind it yeah in a
way a living so happy with himself
you would have that psyches this is it
but this is my call and this is my
sunshine remember that chocolate over a
shotgun on his back when Homer becomes
mr. plow hey coffee you know
they rebook come with me today from off
of Jordan they have got me alienated in
one I've never worn it how was it the
same sir how were you to the same size I
don't know but it fits him I think he
made it fit it says you'll either one
until you know it'll be tight Pacific
Glory's about what I mean it's comments
you can't see because you're in chess
this bodyless harmless unless everything
piss peace so as we move forward towards
the games are there any athletes or
teams or anything that you are surprised
by or the is there any elements moving
forward that you think are going to be
interesting for people to watch like
with so with with athletes uh-huh back
to regionals a little bit as well so I
worked with Kelly Pharrell and Q is
there okay and she had a completely
different mindset to everybody in the
room because she'd already qualified for
the games with the Masters qualifiers
for the 4244 category I was gonna put
was then also deciding also individual
for a bit fabulous just could you can
just because she can't they put in the
back room it was a completely different
scenario that everything I'd seen with
everybody else she's having fun she's
there for training weekend yeah she's
wanted to do the best she could
demonstrate the skills yeah and everyone
was kind of in awe like she's a 40 year
old mama - and she'd worked hard to be
there it's all true interview stats just
like everyone was boldly introducing me
as this yeah yeah to put arms amazing
yeah it was amazing cuz she was just
having a lot we just having their life
in the back room just don't know what to
do she's warmed up she was happy to be
there yeah then he looked around the
room all these Scandinavian birds with
the headphones in like shooting out wife
with the motivational coach sits at the
side saying you can't you can you can
there's been intense day I always want
to rather intense and nobody I know it's
just so so I think I think I think what
all of you are we've kind of just
skipped over I think the mindset thing
is way bigger and and that and I think
there was a lot of people I were just
like I'm a form to go your mindset I
just think it just depends on the
individual doesn't it yeah you guys are
fine but you guys are you guys I do
think I know and I think you've got
people there who like need to tune out
and need to not worry about other stuff
and you see it with certain athletes
like we talked about this spell certain
athletes I mention
with that hobbits changing yeah yeah but
like I don't think that's necessarily a
mindset thing I think it's a Hubbard
thing yeah that's I think that's okay I
think that two different issue okay well
then whether you want to call it Hobbit
thing with this certain characteristics
of certain people sure that you could
predict their failure yeah predict their
outcome or like prior to and things that
they need to change yeah like that you
know answer I'd say that their character
we can all go through semantics of
different terminologies of it but if
someone's doing some habitual [ __ ] which
means you can tell that they're
overcompensating because they're
breaking it yeah and then they get there
and then they actually just [ __ ] their
pants at the star and then feel like
Phil because you know they're worried
mm-hmm then that habitual still has to
be dealt with
mm-hmm I mean oh you could turn now if
they'd have this like like you guys I
quite fix mine set off right you guys
shouldn't be there because you you know
you can't suck it up and you can't deal
with them no but I'm saying that you
have to deal with what you have to do
well it's the core watch the right
person is the cause the right person to
depends on your court your programmer or
what your thing is if you're better warm
them up but you know you can't be might
not necessarily be the same person to
give them a little tickles and tell them
you know stop checking out chicks on
Instagram like you I mean if that's the
thing that they're doing that's causing
them issues are checking out over
athletes and sort of media or [ __ ]
talking yourself or having a really bad
time after a workout these are habitual
things that people are putting a place
where they smell failure in the first
workout and then they and then they go
fail and then you got that guy's then
your other guy in the other region who
was like in the third heat and I last
workout and then you got about the best
time when the games using the crowd
having a beer because he didn't think he
was there everything baby the word in a
corner this time last year as well but
yeah so you know I said I'm from the
Pacific Regional it was like a really
bad health last year Kansas the Pacific
repairs yeah yeah actually a ballast
like a company but he was another bit it
was in the third he on the last year so
it's like no any are going yeah like he
wasn't one of the guys nothing at this
off for something totally boss the final
work out there was like awesome great
weekend winning the crowd sat under fear
the like games the need to call you back
out dude and he's like oh [ __ ] but you
don't mean if
if you're already on the beers after dr1
cost you mean because running on a
treadmill is in your jam and finish it
do you I mean and then and then all
you're gonna do is that yourself decline
and it's like well it's you know I said
there should be a level of autonomy so
at that point you should be prepared to
handle your position like you should
need to while you come and give you a
little hug so afraid why I'm here I
wanted to try yeah exactly I think a lot
of that little can be like can be taken
care of by like people being more
prepared yeah so like if you're going I
think I think I think this stuff needs
to be dialed in now yeah I think I think
if you're going to go if you want to go
to regionals next year and at any point
during the season you sabor oh god did
you see that dude snatch you're like you
need to stop looking at other guys snap
cheers in sight you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
just that not even like the social media
stuff because that's inevitable no but I
think that's the stuff that's the stuff
that I see in the dialogue that I get
because most people contact us through
social media I think more like train and
stuff like you know if you look at that
for those events it's three miles on a
treadmill I don't mean funny but you're
not really that fit can't run three
miles on one of those skill mills when
he's supposed to be one of the top 40
fittest people in here but like have a
word like seriously have a word and you
know people could say that to me and the
contractor well are you want to be on
the edge people hear it contact 110 but
got there but you know that's down to if
we're going down the mindset route which
you know you guys in on into as much and
I'm just like I did hear that would
terminate here it's an auntie that's
reproving isn't it yeah like I've got a
winch here with three miles on the
treadmill actually everyone's gotta
winch you were three miles on the
treadmills and I know that I can set off
more than everyone else
yeah like I'm the dude is gonna puke on
myself and still finish like if you're
going into a prison yeah exactly that's
actually going into it that's very
different cuz they're both looking at
the same thing differently yeah yeah I
mean I feel like to be fair feel I mean
quite dismissive of the mindset stuff
which and don't want to come across as
being dismissive but I've since a bit
arty-farty
personally I think transport but there
is that a lot of nisha underneath where
you can go with like self-talk
preparation is a key thing yeah like
you're talking a lot about prepping I
think it's already deal with a comp you
need you need that whether it's somebody
to talk to you whether if you coach
whether it's just you girlfriend at home
you saying hey look stop looking at
gives me some perspective yeah probably
something's but if you want to take some
time away from that they want to touch
on a few things that we've come up with
there so one of them is I'll ask a bunch
of questions I'll let you all go after
that firstly do you think that athletes
should leave their phones at home for
regionals and do you both down the qiam
yes do you think that that performance
would how much do you think that
performance would either increase
decrease or not change back if they left
the final poll depends Nia you're right
okay but for some individuals so if
there's some individuals yes you're
talking percent like quantifiable
percentages like yeah it could be a reps
reps and places potentially oh yeah but
I think those people are probably then
the people they were watching her around
them but by that stage of the
competition no dream it's not on the
screen and show the women so they're
already kind of they've already set it
in I don't think the problem necessarily
is game there I think the problem is is
how you're perceiving it [ __ ] six
months before I mean if you can't handle
Instagram over a conversation weekend
there's probably some Minds again you've
probably already kind of like defeated
what you term do you think athletes
should maybe consider leave yes on at
home upset not home just await hotel
yes away for the game day probably look
at the leaderboard don't look into it
too much but yet again what Paul was
saying was in the warm-up area
handsome walks over the thing some girls
are crushing it some girls won't you you
instantly compare yourself yeah like
[ __ ] I can't do that but you I mean you
you scale that your capacity to compare
yourself when you access the Internet
yeah yes like Scioscia we went into the
that workout the hunt as a team the
handstand walk one with a lot of waiting
on like we mature everyone in the team
could do the handsome box yeah it got
the game they're actually not everyone
could do them on on the dead you said
just in in the event and in the moment
when the reality is is like we
underperformed on how we've done in the
gym several times but we still got like
seventh in that workout yeah you know I
never very well for probably a lot
higher
yeah but for our point of view all we'd
seen on the internet and on Instagram
was everyone was finished it you know
not 90% of videos on that were people
posting videos of them completing it
almost faceplant off the site but you
did but then it was the next one well if
you're seeing all your people and a
hundred percent of them are finishing it
then you're going to assume a hundred
percent of people can do it that wasn't
real was it this is a microcosm for
social media in general though you see
yesterday I don't see the worst of your
own you don't even recognize people so
if you'll me do a lot of the time no
yeah sure yeah
what about you John what's your thoughts
I don't know I mean personally I always
say - leave my bag low like I don't I'm
quite like children my phone doesn't
bother I don't know you spend a lot of
time on social media like um yeah just
don't doesn't really affect this that's
like I don't really compare myself to us
what what's interesting here is that
you've got you two guys who I definitely
think I've got a innate appropriate
mindset to a degree like it you I'm sure
it could be better but I don't could
definitely I definitely think that for a
lot of people if he said would you like
to swap your mindset with regards to
working out and suffering and enduring
discomfort physically within a sport
with Jordans and Tim's I think a lot of
people would probably go yeah I mean
look at it from that they're like and I
think what you're saying here Paul is
also very valuable about the fact that
there are there are some people that
Jordan you have within your fitness
Arsenal you have certain elements of
which like your ability to do
five-minute double unders and thrusters
workout versus your max of squat snatch
yeah it's weighted in one direction
instead of another yeah but in the same
way as someone's physical capability may
be very heavily weighed away from their
mental capacity yeah let me know all the
mental capacity in the world but if you
can't lift the bar you can't lift the
bar yeah do you not I mean
but like
yeah to a 45 pound thruster and a double
under like there's no physical
limitation stop me doing that there's a
physical limitation with lifts in a bar
you can either do it or you can't yeah
you can either lift the weight oh you
can't lift the weights you know what I
mean I think that's what when you were
talking about reframing yeah I think
that's a good point that I mean I sure
to a degree hundred ten kilos is a it's
a goal for yourself you can using it as
an example it's like the open workout in
2017 which was the squat snatch workout
would you want you watch this do so b4
time PV all times right here oh my god I
came like 510 Europe on that workout I
could look at that and go cheers to Kim
500 I'm looking go RPP 4 times so like
your one rep max much yeah did you
enough to do it loaded with all of those
80 kilo ones which was like you know 83%
of all one at max at the time yeah so
it's like you know I could look at that
and be negative about it and go well I
came 5 hundredths and yet that cost me
going to regionals because I was like
top 50 and the rest of them or I could
look and go well I couldn't have done
any more
I didn't fail if anything actually
exceeded expectations if you said to me
at the beginning of the day you can hit
force not self under kilos it's not a
high five year wouldn't have you burn or
only like you know what I mean like I
know I think this is the mindset that
we've got in our gym though I think
we're lucky because we get that culture
within our gym and buyer is it drip down
compared difficult you Theodore yeah
find out that I think we've got a pretty
good I think
we've managed to like and still pretty
good mindset with us control model so I
think so I think we're quite think in a
gym we're lucky I think a deal don't
worry about the mindset the people we
work with I think they're all but it's
like a people we both parody in the gym
like they're all miss mm-hmm but I think
there is some who segregate themselves
and you can see don't have it often
though and so we're doing some
programming from wherever they just
segregate from all classes go in the
corner and I've got unwrapped 60 burpees
don't give up for like two minutes you
can see them you can see them evening
like snapped workout or hitting the wire
around all those drop back
subconsciously so there's glad to fire
right yeah because there no one there
they're not really countable to anybody
oh I think as well as that they're
probably not that born in mic it's
belief isn't it yeah like leavers well
we've all had programming from different
coaches you know not not the guys that
are sitting here but these guys program
for me now but you know I've had program
from other people in the past where I've
looked at it and it's been really tough
but I've been so bought into it that
I've just gone right well that's what's
required a child want to do it you know
my daughter my my old coach John C had
me doing like for Kelly's so do five
rounds of Kelly whereas five minutes are
four times like two hours mm-hmm and it
was like complete madness
it was rough but I'm just like it was
what it was was rates of wired yeah it
was written down so once it's written
down it has to be done I think that
commitment to wouldn't wavering
commitment to completing the work it's
also a trust as well or you know a coach
you have to fade out of training Roger I
think as well another element of that
what that obviously carries forwards and
you touched on habit before if you have
the idiosyncratic habit of what I see on
paper is what I do yeah image it like
without question I think that the more
that you can cultivate that because I
know you know I sometimes get
programming I've got [ __ ] hell like
you you you make the excuse just as it's
getting hard oh well like you know I I
really do need to get to work now like
I've thought I've got a reason about
that you've always got a reason why yeah
I can drop it off and I think that if
you are getting coaching and this is
powerlifting Johnny from propane let's
say the same thing with the regards to
his powerlifting things some of the
sessions so the volume thing has to do
really quite preferable yeah and one rep
every six minutes
and yeah like it but sometimes sometimes
it's more yeah sometimes that's like
three still three waters yeah three
board price one on those sessions he has
to use the piece of paper as his extra
accountability if the s all in their
written down but I think it's very hard
I think it's very I think it's very
definite when they that's testing to
rely on like just a promise that you
made yourself I said I was going to
complete this work therefore after our
complete ask me was well at the biggest
progress that I ever made is an athlete
and like with my um like mental approach
to training was like even if it's a I've
got four under killing and I do the
first three under twenty what's go
Fonfon it's bro 400-meter run it's not
brutal on its own but one has to do for
them it's rough
laundry Iran 30 war ball state walls
first yeah 34 verse 30 box ships five
runs so there's five rounds of that rest
five minutes to the four-time 20 runs 20
rounds here Ruffin and but like so let's
say you do that in the first three are
under 20 minutes like I used to get if I
didn't get the fourth under 20 minutes
I'd be like field yeah now I'm like well
nah I did the fourth one so at least I
stated did it
it takes me 25 minutes I still completed
the work you know what I mean so it's
cuz I always used to treat training as a
competition whereas you can't you can't
Ramana because if you do you just burn
up your [ __ ] [ __ ] but no you look
amazing yeah you look great my change
Bernardo you're like I'm the polar
opposite of that like I train really bad
but let's compete reasonably well in in
certain competitions depend on the
events do you find ask you the question
do you think that people who have a bad
mindset do you think you can probably
highlight some athletes that require
mindset work by the ones who perform
well in training and badly in
competition I would say many's for a
competition mindset but no he's not a
trainer mindset because people are
trained while in general obviously
clearly motivated it already just
missing that that thing that gets them
to it and that's throughout the training
it probably is rather you know tired you
know
also bingo if it just massively over
training under resting putting a lot of
pressure on myself to try and do well so
do more programs do more are going get
to the competition whether to you open
anything like that then I share of
anything else just not there's nothing
in it I like [ __ ] off work oh I've all
but ran for two years to guess they're
disappointed agree is it you know I
think a lot of the time people
what's the grid Glassman the quote is it
be impressed by intensity not volume or
something like yeah I think it's like a
it's like a fine line that because you
get people who you know they like volume
like I've responded really well the
volume so I do a lot of volume most one
really really well when you've had
muscle fiber analysis to us yes I
actually told you that yeah I respond
well to doing a lot of volume so like
for example Sprint's like kick my ass
but like a 5k run or a 10k run our half
month and I wouldn't be he's broken from
the next day and I said that a different
10k last Sunday and I was broken for
three days but and but you don't even
like my body responds better to that but
I think it just depends on the
individual individuals some people can
only meet train harder to build nature
throws their just okay so some people
tell themselves I need to train today it
really leads back to that Instagram
thing that I've seen some eight seconds
in a day
probably not fourteen still and it is
very yeah so before we wrap up someone
who's listening this podcast is gonna be
about mindset in sport two-degree are
there any resources that you guys think
if someone wants to learn a little bit
more is there anything that's helped you
sort with framing any YouTube videos and
podcasts any ports probably the one a
chat about ice need to chat to is easy I
used to have a reading on it but I think
the home for me
but for me I would just say I'm the Dave
Goggins podcast with Joe Rogan is
actually really interesting in terms of
mindset because he was somebody who you
know came from being an obese out of
shape really demotivated actually quite
seriously ill and somebody's not like
arguably this kind of plant so that's a
really good podcast listen to also any
of the podcasts that I've got like like
Jason I like getting Jason Clippers
podcast as well I'm rapping mentality
obviously he's a guy who's not a
competitive athlete anymore but owns
multiple businesses got a family you
know a daughter that's not very well I
mean I think she's doing better now but
he's got all these things going on his
life and he's still able to train well
run his businesses do the dirty balances
everything quite well yeah so obviously
it's got a pretty clear mindset as to
what he's doing and this stuff's good
that's about it really for me too
anything that you like well not not
really that type of thing book don't
really read too much into it because
it's how but I believe that it's quite
an eight
you can talk to yourself and get around
certain issues in terms of anxiety in
things but like a lot of people tell
themselves the mentally strong but I
would love to try and test that and
catalyze them to get things not to
actually quite liberating things yeah
because what it means a lot of these
problems are sorry that's fine yeah yeah
they'll know the self-created ah you can
get around it or something like that but
the town cells are so mentally strong
till something comes up with a certain
level of threshold when will break them
there is that just and I only percent
agree that these people who do a hashtag
it should be waterboarded
[Laughter]
let's see how long you can really last
for that hashtag with your hard work
pays cash back then even the grant or
the grind fossil line double oh wait can
we buy I like the grind I think it's
good eh one structures which ones grind
you know we put a poem on the Instagram
I would get know about Alex Murphy
prosper on it anyways what's more
important the grinder the hustle and I
think the historian they're just mister
grandfather
yeah it's if you need some form of
mental training I'd get a coach get a
coach who you believe in get some
accountability and get your life take
care of in terms of your programming
your belief your nutrition get all those
aspects dialed in to something where you
believe it might be War II program it
might not be it might be whoever's else
is out there who you think it's aims in
terms of the nutrition like I've tried
to put myself out let certain people all
the time and obviously they didn't have
the belief in me yeah
with certain people but I don't know you
mean yeah people need to find a belief
where they can trust whoever they're
working with yeah and not a yield
recipes like I do think that's a massive
thing I'm if you trust trust the process
you know if you trust the process and
you believe that what your coach or your
new action coach what I was trying to
get you to do and it takes all the
pressure off you training because all
you have to do to turn up I mean the end
of the day your coach like when we
program for someone we want them to win
Yeah right when we really to win
probably slightly more than they want to
and we probably believe in them slightly
more than they believe in themselves and
you do yeah Jeremy never be very few
people in their lives who really want
them to win without any of the
compromises like you know your parents
want you to win but the old
you're gonna have Sunday dinner with him
and maybe after dessert afterwards or
you go home when your mom's made the
saboteurs Anya you're like mom I'm
trying to get shreds sorry sorry so I'm
not going on this is good you know I
mean your parents aren't trying to [ __ ]
you
but they sign the contract people who
want you to win as much as we would do
you mean but then it's like oh well I
don't know if I believe in your like we
[ __ ] believe anymore and we believe
in us but I thought I get that that for
some people it's like it's an ideology
isn't it if you if you resonate with
someone or something it's easier to get
on board with yeah yeah if you're not if
you're not actually where I think I
think that getting that buy-in and I
think this is definitely something that
over the years with specifically with
physio work that I've had done yeah but
also with other bits and pieces
especially rehab routines anything where
you can't immediately see the benefit I
think requires buy-in now you study
example does that I use this example
before so I've done I started journaling
this year people listening will know
what I'm talking about which is a
six-minute diary which you can go I was
in [ __ ] like that
the first 60 pages of this diary you
don't write in it it's these this is the
justification scientifically for why you
are going to do each of these things
this is why it's on a morning this is
why you use a pen and paper this is why
this question gets us this is why this
question gets us these are the studies
that show what effect it will elicit to
you the first 60 pages of reading which
is a high barrier to entry for people to
actually get to the meet invention of
the product but once I've completed that
60 pages I was like father I can sing
the praises of this now yeah I am
Boateng yeah we can you're by other
people in correct this I'm like
absolutely you like look this is I've
had the dream sold to me and I think
that this is a lot of the time you guys
do it definitely I think and the propane
boys do to you under play to a degree
because you know my guys you wouldn't
play your level of expertise because you
take it for granted to a degree and then
when you actually sometimes deploy so I
read a page
of the we donate nutrition the most
recent PDF that you sent out some within
the Oakland guide or maybe I'm not sure
it was one about whether you're eating
carbs before cardio and cups before
weight training I'm gonna get a page on
that and I was like just reading through
about what phosphor creatine's energy
system gets activated through ATP
glucose transfer and a like Tim's Tim's
like a [ __ ] wizard my name is
illegitimate was it like what the [ __ ]
you what's all what is this bro their
degrees people don't need to know it
they just need to know I'm gonna have a
carbohydrate I wasn't but I think it's
disseminating knowledge and I'm not the
complication really provides mate that's
what we do really well we together said
inputting ATP bias programming will put
[ __ ] yourself up yeah I think you're
ugly and people you wanna make is
important though it's important for
people to know that you know that for
them yeah then buy in yeah I've said
I've said to both yourself and use it's
a good example from propane fitness in
six months time we'll be a doctor proper
proper doctor yeah yeah and every so
often during a live stream or something
similar or the same during one of your
PDS you'll read something that kind of
like lets you peer behind the curtain a
bit and you go jesus [ __ ] christ
like I'm aware that I just got to see
like the gossamer thin veneer yes the
disseminated information the top of that
I need to know but there's all there's a
[ __ ] bastard that lives below it and
it's just a ego well and that to me at
personally I think that yeah you don't
want to be swinging your dick around
showing off because you somehow feel
that that makes you like you you're able
to publicly masturbate through a PDF
essentially about how good you are but I
certainly think from my side as a
potential client as a good example for
that I read the first 60 pages six
minute diary and I've just completed it
today
final day and I bought another one
because I want to go again because I
believe in the process and I think part
of that is the justification for where
the end result is come from yeah yeah
and I think that a lot of them a lot of
coaches that I know a lot of people
physios as well like make people believe
in the process like me tell them the
understanding
some people just want to know yeah but
then other people need to understand it
yeah and you said you know some of the
clients you'd say ron paul about some of
the clients need that like that extra
level of care or attention or rigor or
whatever you want to say
so people respond really well to that
and but sometimes they also just need to
just [ __ ] go they just need to do it
and i think yeah but you know I
definitely think from your guys side
like having seen what it is that you
power and how well developed is I
definitely think that that's one of the
things that probably even some of your
athletes need to appreciate a little bit
more like just how much work goes into
that service so anyway thank you very
much guys we will be back with Tim and
potentially someone I potentially just
some cupcakes might bring the dog bring
the whole oh my god could you money no
loud it would be I know that book throw
up when you find five employees like
that just four in two days like it's
quite a lot for me that before all the
settings ammonium with caffeine fingers
I mean anything's does nothing to come
on Alex Miller yeah I spoke to took an
imodium every day for free where except
is all more than Jim why because you
like it cuz you weird and then he did
Mount Kilimanjaro every life you got the
[ __ ] up a mountain and wiping his hands
and after I got over it well on that
bombshell sorry to ruin your ending and
I'm a nutrition built up north worried
programming Reebok CrossFit answered
everything to be in the show notes thank
you very much for ceasing
[Music]
you